[Musique]
sommes au début d'une renaissance
il y faudra de la détermination et du
courage le courage de dire et le courage
de faire nous allons faire renaître un
espoir à droite
nous allons écrire une renaissance et
c'est la renaissance de notre nation que
nous proposons aux français
je veux reconstruire la droite
je veux tourner la page des divisions et
de ses erreurs du passé et je veux le
faire avec une nouvelle génération une
génération qui a du courage une
génération perdue sous les électeurs de
droite ont exprimé leur volonté de
prendre un nouveau départ avec
l'élection de laurent wauquiez
ce renouveau il a souhaité l'insuffler
en désignant une nouvelle équipe
paritaire jeunes et exprimant des
sensibilités différentes de la droite
avec cette équipe
les républicains tourner la page des
divisions des renoncements
notre objectif est clair avoir une
droite qui s'assume offensive déterminer
qui aussi s'adresse à la majorité
silencieuse et notamment aux plus
exposés et aux plus fragiles d'entre
nous la famille les républicains et
droite est les deux tours elle assume la
totalité de ses valeurs elle ira
jusqu'au bout de ses idées à droite de
retour c'est celle qui est ferme sur les
sujets régaliens de l'autorité de la
sécurité de la protection nos
concitoyens contre le terrorisme contre
le délitement de l'état contre l'abandon
de certains quartiers de la république
le gouvernement est trop souvent dans la
naïveté est toujours dans les mots il
est désormais temps d'agir
il est temps d'assurer la protection des
français qui assiste impuissant au défi
lancé quotidiennement à notre république
n'accepterons aucune compromission les
républicains assumant où l'idéal
d'une droite forte et intransigeante la
droite de retour c'est celle qui défend
l'identité de la france est le modèle
d'intégration républicain
petit à petit nous avons cessé de
transmettre la fierté de notre histoire
nous avons cru qu'il fallait
déconstruire pour accommoder la
diversité nous avons laissé le discours
communautarisme s'installe il est
remplacé la fierté de ce qu'est la
france
la laïcité est un principe fondamental
de notre république
aujourd'hui en france elle est sans
cesse attaqué il est temps d'ouvrir les
yeux et ne pas se tromper de combat il
est temps de dire que la france n'a pas
à se renier pour réussir il est temps de
faire à nouveau aimer la france la
droite de retour c'est celle qui défend
la france de la province celle qui dès
france ce que les géographes appelle la
france périphérique
cette france qui a été oublié par la
mondialisation galopante qui a profité à
certains mais qui a déclassé d'autres
c'est celle qui s'adresse aux ruraux qui
considère que loin de la technocratie
parisienne méprisante
il y a une valeur ajoutée la ruralité et
ses habitants incarne une véritable
promesse de développement pour notre
pays
à une condition c'est que nous nous en
donnions les moyens
c'est cette france des pme c'est cette
france des agriculteurs
c'est cette france des retraités c'est
cette france des familles aujourd'hui
trop oubliée du gouvernement qui la
matraquer fiscalement comme le montre
l'augmentation vertigineuse de la csg
c'est cette france là pour laquelle nous
nous battons c'est cette france là pour
laquelle la droite est de retour la
droite de retour c'est celle qui va
puiser dans le passé
la force de reprendre le drapeau et de
mener des combats pour l'avenir de notre
pays
la droite de retour c'est celle qui veut
écrire fièrement une nouvelle page de
l'histoire de la droite française a
droit de retour c'est celle qui incarne
un nouvel espoir aux côtés de laurent
wauquiez
[Musique]